[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA Qatar 2022 a
continuación nuestros titulares
Alemania logró sacarle un empate a
España en el último duelo de la jornada
de este domingo un punto que le da un
respiro pese a ellos y sus dirigidos no
pasan el susto y se jugarán la
continuidad en el Torneo frente a Costa
Rica el próximo jueves tenemos análisis
Costa Rica venció a Japón en el inicio
de la jornada y retomó aspiraciones de
clasificarse nuevamente a los octavos de
final de una copa del mundo su técnico
Luis Fernando Suárez también anhela el
objetivo y sería la segunda vez que lo
logra en tres mundiales como técnico
[Música]
Marruecos dio la campanada y se ubicó
segundo en el grupo F fue la primera
Victoria del conjunto marroquí ante los
Diablos Rojos belgas por una copa del
mundo tenemos detalles
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio sasso periodista de la emisora
Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido Octavio
Hola Luis un gusto saludarte como
siempre y aprovecho también para darle
la bienvenida a nuestra enviada especial
en catar Natalia Ruiz quien nos trae
todos los detalles de primera mano de lo
que está ocurriendo en esa nación
Saludos Natalia
Hola muy buenas noches
y así comenzamos
Alemania en apenas dos jornadas de la
Copa del Mundo estaba en una posición
complicada perder ante Japón y con
España como segundo rival le dieron un
agregado a la rivalidad hispano germana
nunca antes vista en otro torneo el
juego fue entretenido que además dejó
Clara la idea de juego de los españoles
pero dejó también al descubierto las
dificultades alemanas al final un uno a
uno gracias a los tantos de Álvaro
morata para España y de niclas para los
hermanos este resultado le da oxígeno
flick pero aún tienen una batalla más
que dar Natalia cómo se vivió ese
partido en en Qatar y Qué sensación
tuvieron los alemanes tras este
resultado
pues se fue un tremendo partido sobre
todo una gran un gran ambiente aquí en
este estadio el 20 con tantísimos
hinchas sobre todo muchos categorías que
estaban a favor de España se escuchó
desde el comienzo desde que se
escucharon las notas de el himno
nacional Pues en que había un gran
fervor por parte de los hinchas
españoles y de los que estaban apoyando
a la roja efectivamente lo que pudimos
ver fue durante la primer tiempo pues
una defensa alemana bastante nerviosa
con esas primeras llegadas incluso la de
Danny olmo a la comienzo de este de ese
de ese primer tiempo con una España
bastante organizada jugando un fútbol
bastante bonito de muchísimos pases que
da preguntas un poco sobre ese digamos
no tanto el esquema sino la táctica que
quiere Luis Enrique imponer en este
equipo a veces con esos pases hacia
atrás que llegan hasta una y Simón El
Arquero y que por poco pues se pone en
aprie aún más a los españoles por parte
de los alemanes pues simplemente ese ese
gran trabajo que tienen ellos a nivel
defensivo preguntas también sobre porque
no entra desde el comienzo a este
partido porque fue mucho más incisivo Y
pues obviamente el autor de este tanto
para empatar este partido y para que
Alemania Pues continúe con vida en este
mundial
hablaba Natalia Octavio de ese juego
bonito que ha planteado España a lo
largo de esta copa del mundo pero en
este caso vamos a referirnos a Alemania
Qué está pasando con el juego alemán
quedaron fuera en Rusia No tuvieron una
buena Eurocopa y ahora están enfrentando
problemas para poder avanzar en esta
llave que Lucía accesible para ellos en
un primer momento exactamente Luis hoy
era la prueba de fuego evidentemente
porque enfrentaban un rival de su misma
categoría era el primer partido en esta
copa del mundo que enfrentaba a dos
campeones de del mundial Y esa
posibilidad evidentemente les iba a
generar el hecho de saber en dónde están
parados enfrentarse a un equipo de ese
nivel como España les permitiría
entender Si el equipo alemán está para
competir en esta copa del mundo si
definitivamente no no le va a alcanzar Y
hoy por momentos del partido Alemania
superó a España en momentos del partido
digamos tuvo un juego más fluido que
evidentemente contra Japón se encontró
contra un rival que le permitió otro
tipo de espacios que no lo hago como
Japón sobre todo en el segundo tiempo y
Alemania tuvo la posibilidad incluso de
generar esas ocasiones de Gol apareció
el goleador Alemán de raza sobre sobre
el final para para empatar el partido un
hombre que incluso no estaba en la
convocatoria inicial que fue
prácticamente descartado que entró sobre
el final por las lesiones que tuvo
Alemania pero creo que empieza a cambiar
un poco el ánimo del equipo e incluso
Luis perdiendo Alemania Todavía tenía
posibilidades de clasificarse entonces
con este empate yo creo que ahora
Alemania va a tener que jugársela frente
a Costa Rica Pero sabiendo que vuelven a
ser los alemanes no un duelo que será
muy interesante para el cierre de la
jornada de este grupo pero hablando de
Costa Rica en San José la capital de ese
país se arramó la fiesta la gente salió
a las calles para celebrar lo que fue la
sexta Victoria en una copa del mundo
para la selección de ese país un triunfo
que le ayuda a la afición a recuperar
confianza luego de haber iniciado con el
pie izquierdo su participación al ser
derrotados por España
3 por 0 en Qatar Costa Rica se impuso Un
gol por cero a Japón un partido donde
los nipones tuvieron más la pelota
atacaron más remataron tres veces al
arco pero que hicieron fuller jugador
que pertenece al herediano en su país
colocó un globo por encima del Arquero
sushiconda para sellar la victoria
Octavio qué podemos decir de esta
selección de Costa Rica y la manera que
se recompone de un 7 a 0 sin hacer su
mejor fútbol pero consiguiendo un
resultado positivo obviamente Luis este
resultado como bien lo dice es positivo
les da oxígeno al equipo de Luis
Fernando Suárez pero futbolísticamente
no cambió nada
Costa Rica tiene un solo disparo al arco
en 180 minutos y ese disparo largo entró
con con digamos con el triunfo y la
posibilidad que le genera ese disparo de
fuller para que Costa Rica dejen el
camino a Japón pero evidentemente nada
ha cambiado es decir trataron de
mantener el partido 0 a 0 trataron de
resguardarse para que Japón que fuese
cansando de ser el protagonista del
partido el equipo que generará las
ocasiones Japón ralentizó el partido
sobre todo en el primer tiempo fue un
partido muy lento que se hace el más
lento de lo que hemos visto en esta en
esta fase de grupos del mundial y Costa
Rica lo que hizo fue esperar a que
tuviese una posibilidad o que Japón se
equivocara una vez y aprovechó para
marcar el golpe pero yo creo que le va a
costar mucho Costa Rica para mí Luis se
va a quedar en el camino Costa Rica no
genera fútbol no genera posibilidad de
gol y aunque hoy descansen y Duerman
tranquilos porque se quitaron de encima
la presión del Siete a cero la verdad es
que futbolísticamente están jugando muy
poco y no recuerdo un poco ese Alemania
2006 cuando iniciaron también con una
goleada en contra por parte del conjunto
alemán pero Natalia vimos como
disfrutaron la victoria en San José
sabemos que los parciales de Costa Rica
también montaron esa fiesta en Qatar
pero quisiera saber cómo asumió El
Triunfo Luis Fernando Suárez que voy a
citar calificó como accidente lo
ocurrido frente a España
Sí así después de alguna manera como
ustedes bien venían hablando de de de lo
que significa finalmente este Este
triunfo para para los ticos Pues de
alguna manera hace que Luis Fernando
Suárez no solamente pueda volver a
respirar sino que también el que ha sido
pues tan tan cuestionado precisamente
después de esa humillación que tuvo la
sele ante España Pues de alguna manera
puede que calle boca sobre todo porque
acaba de ganarle a un equipo como Japón
que venía Pues de ese triunfo histórico
de dos goles por uno ante ante Alemania
pero efectivamente creo que lo otro es
ver que ahora pues de todas maneras
varios no puede decir Bueno vamos a
salir a ganar ese próximo partido que se
viene el próximo jueves va a ser muy
complicado es un partido que además va a
disputarse aquí en el 20 y muy
seguramente pues era la hinchada alemana
la que sea pues la mayoría así que por
ahora no se puede cantar Victoria Pero
de alguna manera pues se saca un poco
del de la del a la técnico
colombiano que entrena a los a los ticos
interesante este planteamiento Natalia
siempre es bueno un respiro antes de
afrontar una batalla como la que le
corresponde al conjunto costarricense
pero hablemos de Marruecos porque esta
selección está en su sexta participación
en una copa del mundo y hasta hoy
solamente acumulaba dos triunfos todos
ante rivales europeos Portugal en 1986 y
Escocia en la Copa del Mundo de 1988 de
1998 este domingo consiguió su tercer
triunfo al vencer a Bélgica dos goles
por cero este resultado no lo califico
como el más importante porque la
victoria en el 86 le valió para ser
líderes de su grupo en aquel entonces
por encima de Inglaterra y Polonia que
se clasificaron segunda y tercera
respectivamente pero bajo las
circunstancias del fútbol actual y del
nivel de los jugadores belga en clubes
europeos creo que toma unas dimensión
especial Octavio cuál podría ser la
clave de Este triunfo marroquí Y qué
está pasando con Bélgica que no
pareciera ser la misma de Hace cuatro
años y no querer Buscar el mundial Sí
fíjate
luego de escuchar las declaraciones de
sus máximas figuras por un lado decís
que es el hombre del Chelsea que qué
bueno que marcó el primer gol y que es
una de las figuras de este equipo
marroquí el comentado después del
partido que para ello fue más fácil
enfrentar a Bélgica que jugar frente a
Croacia porque Bélgica los dejaba
manejar la pelota en la mitad de la
cancha porque les daba más espacios Y
eso lo aprovechaba El Talento marroquí
Fíjate que lo hablamos en estos días
como se han cortado las fronteras en el
fútbol hoy 8 de esos 11 jugadores
marroquí del arranque no nacieron en
Marruecos y Y eso Y además la mayoría de
esos jugadores juegan en equipos de gran
nivel encabezados que juega en la
Premier League con el Chelsea juega muy
bien al fútbol este equipo hoy se
sintieron mucho más cómodos se sintieron
mucho más sueltos en la cancha y
aprovecharon que Bélgica está digamos
pasando la pasándola muy mal el equipo
de Roberto Martínez
como decía Kevin de Brian la semana les
pasó el tren esta gran generación cree
en ellos que ya que ya les pasó la La
gran posibilidad que en el mundial
pasado y la verdad es que tienen más
miedo de perder que salir a ganar y eso
hace que bélica se encuentre siempre con
una pared y esta vez le aparece se llama
Marruecos ya revisaremos más adelante si
esos comentarios de Queen serían
impactantes o influyeron en este
resultado frente a Marruecos avanzamos
con más de la copa del mundo porque
Canadá ilusionó a sus parciales y a
muchos en el mundo al anotar el gol más
rápido en lo que va de esta copa Alfonso
Davis puso el tanto que además de
colocar al frente a su selección fue el
primer gol de Canadá en sus
participaciones mundialistas que son dos
la primera en 1986 Croacia después del
tanto enmendó y pudo conseguir un
resultado final de cuatro goles por uno
Octavio un buen triunfo para Croacia
pero queremos le costó mostrarse como
esa selección que fue su campeona Hace
cuatro años sí al final Luis ellos
terminaron digamos resolviendo el
partido esperando los errores de Canadá
que dio algunas ventajas sobre todo en
el segundo tiempo yo creo que la
diferencia 41 no es la justa la verdad
es que es que parece un golpe muy
excesivo para para Canadá que estaba
jugando bien que era un equipo que que
alegró que alimentó a la gente que dio
la posibilidad de que el fútbol en
norteamericano tuviese un gran
protagonista pero Croacia tiene eso
tiene experiencia tiene jerarquía tiene
el hecho de haber jugado una copa del
mundo como la pasada y serlo
subcampeones sabe manejar los tiempos
del partido entonces Croacia fue
aprovechando los espacios que le daba
Canadá para ir dando golpecitos y al
final ese error grosero que hace la
defensa de Canadá para que tenga la
posibilidad del equipo croata de
conseguir el 4-1 pero a partir de ahora
Canadá va a estar mucho más cómodo se
soltó y evidentemente también como en el
primer partido que le costó frente a
Marruecos Ahora tiene la facilidad de
saberse que que tiene cuatro puntos y
que puede caminar más tranquilo
podríamos hablar de Canadá de tener ya
para lo que va a ser la Copa del año
2026 sí claramente Canadá tenía que
valorar Luis la experiencia de estar en
un mundial este grupo de jugadores no
podía seguir cargando digamos ese lastre
de no haber marcado un gol en mundial es
de no tener esa posibilidad y hoy aunque
el equipo este golpeado anímicamente
Aunque repito haya sido un golpe
demasiado excesivo Alfonso Davis y sus
compañeros van a tener esa experiencia
para poder afrontar el mundial de 2026
Sabiendo ya Cómo se juega una una copa
del mundo a continuación una selección
de noticias
el actual seleccionador de Irán el
portugués Carlos queiroso calificó como
escandalosos los comentarios del
exjugador y es técnico de la selección
alemana jorgen griezmann sobre el
combinado iraní y su seleccionador
queiros que busca avanzar a los octavos
de final con el conjunto persa pidió la
dimisión del alemán en su cargo dentro
de la FIFA
la federación de fútbol de Francia
podría recibir una sanción debido a que
el jugador kylian mbappé se ha negado en
dos ocasiones a declarar a los medios la
última tras el partido frente a
Dinamarca de acuerdo con medio franceses
citados por el portal argentino tyc
Sports la decisión de mbappé guardar
relación con su incierto futuro dentro
del París Saint Germain
en la selección brasileña y optimismo
respecto a la recuperación del jugador
Neymar la versión brasileña del portal
World ha manifestado que el jugador se
mostró con un tobillo menos inflamado el
cuerpo técnico espera el resultado del
partido frente a Suecia para determinar
si le otorgarán una jornada de descanso
más y poder estar en los octavos
a continuación la agenda de partidos
para este lunes
la jornada inicia bien temprano para el
continente americano cuando las
representaciones de Camerún c y Serbia
salten a la cancha en la búsqueda de sus
primeros puntos en este torneo
posteriormente en el tercer duelo de la
jornada Brasil está enfrentando a Suiza
ambos están pensando en la clasificación
recordemos que por Brasil no estará
jugando Neymar por presentar una lesión
la jornada por el grupo H la abren los
países de Cana y Corea del Sur en el
cierre del día se espera el Duelo entre
Portugal y Uruguay Cristiano Ronaldo
Joao Félix y Compañía estarán
enfrentando al Luis Suárez Edison cavani
y Diego gonín pedíamos veremos quién
gana
ya que hablamos de los partidos de este
lunes uno que guarda mucha atención es
el de Portugal y Uruguay ya que se
enfrentaron en los octavos de final Hace
4 años pero quisiera saber para ti
Natalia Cuál es el partido que más te
llama la atención en esta jornada
pues ese partido suena interesante Luis
Pero quizás el que más me interesaría
ver sería el de Brasil a Suiza empezando
para para ver digamos Cuál es el
planteamiento de tité ahora que no
contará ni con a Neymar ni con Danilo
ahora y lo otro es que a lo largo de de
lo que hemos visto en este mundial es
que las grandes favoritas en realidad en
el segundo partido no les ha ido muy
bien es lo que ha sucedido por ejemplo
incluso con Japón que se esperaba que
hiciera mucho más el día de hoy a España
se esperaba que ganara a Alemania a
pesar de que se sabía desesperado que
fuera un partido bastante difícil entre
ambos Así que mañana pues Brasil tendría
la oportunidad finalmente de
consolidarse como esa gran favorita
porque por ahora pues es solamente
Francia la que ya ganó sus dos partidos
y ya pasó a octavos Así que mañana ese
sería digamos el partido en el por el
que estaré ahí muy pendiente Muchísimas
gracias Natalia por todas tus
intervenciones Octavio volver a
preguntarte por ese partido Portugal y
Uruguay prácticamente las mismas nóminas
de Hace cuatro años pero quién pudiese
tener ya la ventaja en esta fase de
grupos es el típico partido Luis para
los uruguayos que saben que con un punto
y enfrentando un rival de esas
características en el que todo el mundo
da como favorito a Portugal y en el que
ellos tienen que conseguir un buen
resultado para seguir en camino les
permitirá la posibilidad de siempre de
ir desde atrás como como la garra
charrúa que los representa Entonces es
el típico partido para ellos con la
experiencia de cavani de Suárez de los
jugadores que tiene Uruguay y a ver cómo
reacciona Portugal frente a un rival
totalmente diferente a gana el que tuvo
en el primer partido un rival que no lo
va a dejar tener espacio y que no lo va
a dejar jugar Tan sencillo Así que ese
es el partido que que más me llama la
atención Muchísimas gracias Octavio por
todo tu análisis a lo largo de este
espacio también a Natalia Ruiz desde
Qatar a ustedes por estar con nosotros
continúen con masa de la programación de
Fran 24 y de France 24.com
[Música]